well space was once the domain of large
government agencies think
nasa or russia's ros cosmos now
increasingly private companies are the
ones moving in
space it turns out is big business
especially as demand for satellites
grow now currently are about 3 000
satellites in orbit
the us by far has the greatest number
followed by
china and russia however more and more
countries and companies
are getting into the mix so things are
about to get more crowded especially as
companies lead on satellites for
applications such as land mapping or gps
now here's a look at what soon could be
cruising in lower earth orbit
as you can see the current number there
around 3300 elon musk's star
link his company wants to send more than
40 000 satellites
into space in the coming years amazon
plans more than 3 000 which seems like a
tiny number compared to that one
but still almost double what's already
up there so who's delivering those
satellites
that's where the market is growing
is this germany's answer to spacex
the spectrum carrier rocket is due for
takeoff next year
this small launch vehicle has a diameter
of just two meters
and a payload of only one thousand
kilograms
if you look at the technical
developments in the recent
decade or the recent two decades you see
that satellites
keep becoming smaller and smaller so the
demand
goes away from the very heavy lift
launch vehicles that have been developed
in
mainly institutional development
programs to
small vehicles that can serve those
dedicated small launch demands
mini rockets for many satellites the
startup
is our aerospace was founded three years
ago by students in munich
it now employs 150 staff from 30
countries
the prototype is already on display but
we're not allowed to film it
for now everything is strictly under
wraps
building a rocket is the most difficult
thing you can do from
a technological point of view you are
moving in
areas of technology where you need to go
to the absolute
limits of what is achievable with
current technology
the journey to space will start in
norway
where a launch site for small satellites
is currently under construction
spectrum has reserved one of the two
launch pads
many believe that space industry will be
the
fastest growing industry in the next
decades
and the coming decades and i think this
is correct
first of all due to the increased use of
data from satellites in
earth observation communication
navigation all kind of infrastructure
and all and a modern society is
dependent on the infrastructure in space
several satellites but only a few launch
vehicles
this is the gap in the market is our
aerospace wants to fill
demand is already high as soon as the
norwegian launch site is completed
it will be time for takeoff
i'm joined now by ulrich valter he's a
former astronaut for germany and payload
expert and he's a professor
at technical university of munich it's
great to have you on the show
izar was founded by one of your former
students
is it alone in this field to some extent
or will we see more startups like it
in the future there are already many
startups all
also in germany there's one in augsburg
called
rocket factory augsburg and there's
another one even
called uh high impulse which is uh
located in
back so actually in german we have three
and
well there will be competition but
that's good
what is it that's driving this growth we
saw a bit about those smaller satellites
is that really what's behind it is that
making it more accessible
yes well first it's money of course but
there's a market already
because the classical satellite
providers
they built satellites about two to three
tons
weight today you can build satellites
down to 100 kilograms
usually they are now about two or three
hundred kilograms so they build
new rockets which can take two or three
satellites
so in total about 500 to 1 tons 500
kilograms to one ton
and that's a new class of satellites the
old providers the classical providers
they don't care about those satellites
they care only about these big
satellites
so actually there's a new niche about
new satellites
is that accessible considering the money
that's out there obviously startups see
large amounts of money coming in but
we're talking about rockets and
launching satellites in the space
is there the kind of money out there to
support all these startups
oh yes there is a money even the
classical satellite providers
are building down or sizing down their
satellites to these very small
satellites about
only a couple of hundred kilograms so
the market is there
however the old providers like ariana
they cannot change their rocket
they have the big rockets and they need
to have big satellites
to bring them in geostationary or orbit
they cannot suddenly switch from a big
to a small
rocket do you expect to see any
crossover between these private efforts
and
europe's public efforts which it's also
trying to boost um
to to do more in space frankly
well what we see is that isa like nasa
supports these small companies space
companies
in building smaller satellites and
rockets
but it's not like that in nasa let me
give you an example
esa doesn't say please provide a rocket
for our purposes
that's not what they're doing nasa does
it they go to elon musk and say
please build a rocket that we can fly to
the international space station
so it's still different however either
supports
those small startup companies i have to
ask you
can you imagine space tourism coming to
europe as well you've been to space you
know the draw you know how many people
want to go up there could you see that
briefly if you can oh yes there's a big
space tourism marcus yeah that's true
it will start most probably this next
year with branson he's flying a
suborbital
flight sub orbital means not going
around earth but just
going up and coming down going to space
yes
people are paying for that the current
price is price is 250
000 bucks for flight which takes about
an hour or so
so the market is there and the most
important point about that
is that it lets the prices drop not only
for
flight but but the total prices
for the entire market ulrich volta
astronaut for germany thank you so much